Bertha's family is trying
desperately to break in.
She's very socially ambitious,
and what that means is that she
has to sort of break the code.
♪ (LIVELY
ORCHESTRAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
This sort of stunt
does not impress
the people you want to win over.
Mrs. Morris, this sort of stunt
impresses everyone.
CARRIE COON: She is new money.
She's part of this
new wave of industrialists,
so her husband has gotten his
hand into the railroad industry,
and they've made a fortune
very rapidly.
But, of course,
the old money families
are trying to protect
their position
as the American aristocracy.
I don't know which is worse,
the noise of the builders
or the chance of running
into her in the street.
COON: Bertha has a neighbor
across the street,
Agnes van Rhijn, and her sister
living in a brownstone.
They're part
of the old money families.
They're sort of
more socially conservative.
They're not flashy
with their wealth.
And Bertha Russell has moved in
and built
this palatial residence right
across the street from them,
and they won't look her
in the eye.
And so part of the arc
of the season for her
is trying to figure out
how to position herself
so that Agnes van Rhijn has
to acknowledge that she exists.
She becomes a real foil
for Bertha.
She represents everything
Bertha isn't.
I was also really drawn
to playing Bertha because
I found the marriage between
George and Bertha Russell
really compelling.
It struck me
as shockingly egalitarian
for the time that this is set.
I love that they're really
in this together.
There are moments, my dear,
when you are quite marvelous.
Useless, each without the other.
COON: You get the sense that
they're very compatible,
and they're hungry
for the next step.
I just found
that really thrilling.
What I am planning may take
a great many dollars, my dear.
We've made one fortune together.
If needs be, we'll make
and spend another.
COON: I also think it's a really
interesting time to consider
how we feel about how
these billionaires are living,
and the way
that wealth is flaunted
in spite of tremendous hardship.
And, of course, in addition
to that, all the dynamics
of love and family and marriage,
and people wanting to fit in,
and wanting to know
what their place is.
BERTHA RUSSELL:
We're finally getting
to where we belong.
MORGAN SPECTOR: George is
a fist in a velvet glove, right?
He is a late 19th century
industrialist.
A robber baron.
What will you do
if he won't play ball?
Build another line,
right alongside his.
He is based a little bit
on Jay Gould.
Gould was really vilified
in the papers of the time.
He was someone who became
a kind of living embodiment of
all of the inequality
of the era.
Russell has more money
than God.
SPECTOR: He has such
insane levels of power.
And sometimes he uses them
on really vulnerable people,
and just crushes them like ants.
You bastard.
I may be a bastard,
Mr. Thorburn,
but you are a fool.
George, at home,
kind of gets his ass kicked.
I have a favor to ask.
You mean you want something,
and you haven't asked
your mother.
He is most fundamentally
a family man.
I mean, a person
who's really driven
by his love for his children.
There's a sense of George
holding his power in reserve.
I said I had no objection, but
she had to get your permission.
I will decide who comes
to dinner in this house.
George's relationship
with Bertha is, for me,
at the heart of the show.
I just like you to be happy.
And I know my loving you
is not enough.
It's almost enough.
She has that kind of desire
for power.
But because of the era
in which she lived,
the way that that gets
to express itself
is in this quest
for social status.
And I think George
sort of understands
this is what she has,
and so he facilitates it,
and fights for it
on her behalf,
because she cares about it
and so he cares about.
You and Mrs. Morris have
snubbed and belittled my wife.
How could I allow that
to go unpunished?
There's something very romantic
about that.
It's just fascinating.
There's an aspect of George
where he gives his own fury
free reign sometimes.
I'm afraid you must face
the music.
It's why the sort of duality of
being this very warm family man,
but in business,
being just utterly,
almost inhuman,
is fascinating.
HARRY RICHARDSON:
Larry was just such a kind
and excitable young man.
I really related
to his drive
to try to figure out
where he sits in everything.
And what sort of man
he's going to be.
♪ (CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Larry is the young, happy,
go-lucky son
of George and Bertha Russell.
He's a recent Harvard grad,
and he comes back from school
to try and figure out
where his place is in society,
and in the world,
and in his family.
Larry's relationship
with his parents
is pretty cheeky and fun.
He loves both of them very much.
He really adores his mother
and he'll wind her up
and make fun
of the things that she holds
very dear.
Well, obviously,
my mother couldn't live
in a house without a ballroom.
(CHUCKLES) You may laugh,
but as my mother
never tires of pointing out,
our future success in New York
depends entirely
on this important approval
of Mrs. Astor.
HARRY: Larry's relationship
with Gladys
is really sweet.
They really are best friends,
and he looks after her
and really sticks up for her
when she needs someone
in her corner to fight
against her controlling mom.
She's not a child anymore.
And you shouldn't treat her
as one.
She's a child until I say.
He's a little bit
of a disruptor
within his family.
He's obviously got all
of these societal expectations
of who he's meant to be,
and what job he's meant
to undertake,
and who he's meant
to be partnered with.
And he has a little bit of cheek
and starts to reject
and question some of the things
that are expected of him.
I should get going,
I'm catching
the 11 o'clock train
to Rhode Island.
But you've only just got home.
(CHUCKLES) Is that
what this is?
Gladys has a bit
of a rebellious nature,
just a hint of it.
She doesn't always want
to conform
to the rules of high society.
♪ (ORCHESTRAL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Gladys is the daughter
of the richest new money family,
the Russells.
She, like any teenager
on the brink of adulthood,
is craving her own independence
and the chance to experience
the world.
SPEAKER:
I trust you'll take our part.
I certainly intend to.
My daughter isn't out yet.
She's only here to accompany me.
But she's stuck.
She's stuck with the mother
who has so much control
over her.
She's stuck in a society
where young women
are not allowed to have
their own identities
or enjoy a sense of freedom
without a husband.
How strange these rules are.
Why shouldn't you go out
to dinner
with your brother and a friend?
-What could be more normal?
-Not to my mother.
There's a mutual respect
between Gladys
and her brother Larry.
They both bond
over their struggle
with the unfair expectations
of their parents.
I suppose Mother's made
another quarrel.
I'm afraid I can't stay either.
I just wanted to look in to pay
my respects to your parents.
-I hope we can meet again.
-I'm sure we will.
For Gladys, she enjoys
the fancy dresses
and the French chef
and the butlers and the maids
and all that, but she feels like
she could give all that up
just to be happy. She doesn't
have that same desire
or desperation to be accepted
into high society
the way that her mother,
Bertha, does.
I gather we're going to christen
the new house.
Just a few people calling in,
but I think it's time.
How many are coming?
It's hard to say as they
don't accept in a formal way,
but I think if we cater
for 200,
-it's probably safe.
-Wow!
In this world of fancy dinners
and ball gowns
and etiquette classes,
Gladys can sometimes feel like
more of a doll than a human
and feels like
she's suffocating sometimes,
and it's all for the sake
of a future
that's not even hers.
Mother, may I present
Mr. van Rhijn?
How do you know my daughter,
sir?
Well, I don't. Not really.
But I want to very much.
We cannot always have
what we want.
JACK GILPIN:
Church is the kind of person
when he sees something
that's not happening right,
he goes to it.
He doesn't walk past it.
Church relates differently
to Mr. and Mrs. Russell each.
GEORGE RUSSELL:
Is Mrs. Russell at home?
She's in the drawing room, sir,
with Mrs. Morris.
Is she, indeed?
Well, I won't disturb them.
GILPIN: I love my relationship
with Mr. Russell.
We don't have much to say
to each other,
but when he has something
to say to me, I know
it's gonna be of substance,
and I know he values my advice.
It's thought of
as a male-dominated culture,
which it was,
but that was in one area.
In the realm of the home
and the household,
women called the shots.
The household is an enterprise,
which can be more successful
and less successful,
and Church has a big investment
in the success
of that enterprise
as Mrs. Russell does.
And is everything ready
for Mr. Larry's return?
I believe so, madam, but I will
check with Mrs. Bruce.
Thank you, Church.
Mrs. Russell wants
very passionately
to establish a beachhead
in New York society.
I want to help her do that.
He is the butler.
It's his job to do this,
but he would do it anyway.
In this kind of household,
there are three principal heads
of the staff.
There's the butler, the cook,
and the housekeeper.
The butler has overall
responsibility
for the management
of the household.
We live together,
so it's not like
a normal business relationship.
We have to get along.
This house is a folly.
With one exception
in this staff,
I have a great relationship
with them.
Well, Miss Turner, I hope
you can overcome your distaste
and give the mistress
a helping hand
with her clothes
for the evening.
GILPIN:
Turner, the ladies' maid,
we have
kind of a hostile relationship.
I like Church.
He has a lot of pride,
professional pride,
and I admire that a lot.